reports are coming in that hundreds have
been injured in fresh clashes
in jerusalem police have fired stun
grenades and
tear gas at stone throwing demonstrators
inside the al-aqsa mosque
compound plans to evict palestinian
residents from east jerusalem to make
room for jewish settlers have
fueled protests that escalated over the
weekend
and today tensions are particularly high
as
israel is marking jerusalem day the
anniversary of when
israeli troops captured east jerusalem
in nineteen sixty seven
amid growing international calls for
calm the un security council is holding
an emergency session to discuss the
situation
confrontation
and escalation
[Music]
it's an entrenched pattern of behavior
between jewish israelis and arab
palestinians
who make claims to the same land
[Music]
this time the hatred flared at the
damascus gate
at the entrance to the old city
[Music]
ownership of land is at the heart of the
bitter dispute
the prospect of forced evictions of
palestinians from east jerusalem has
brought arabs to the streets
over the past two weeks hundreds of them
have been injured
as israeli police cracked down on the
demonstrations
on sunday they were out again ahead of a
controversial jerusalem day march
through the old city hardline israeli
nationalists used the annual event to
celebrate the capture of east jerusalem
by israeli forces in the 1967 war
israeli security officials warn it could
lead to a further escalation in violence
and we're joined by our correspondent in
jerusalem tanya
kramer tanya that contentious
march is expected to take place by
israelis today in jerusalem how much
potential
is there for the violence to escalate
well as you said it's it's a very
difficult day in jerusalem
israelis celebrate jerusalem day which
marks the capture of east jerusalem
in 1967 and the reunification of
of jerusalem but that is of course from
an israeli point of view
palestinians want to see east jerusalem
as their future
capital and they see this as a
provocation it's a very difficult day um
usually the route goes
from uh through east jerusalem to
palestine through palestinian
neighborhoods through
one of the main gates damascus gate and
then through the muslim quarter now we
heard
we understand that israeli security
officials even have warned
that under the current circumstances
that the route at least
or the route should be changed
but we haven't heard anything uh to that
regard what has
been decided is to uh close the temple
mount of the haram al-sharif
with the al-aqsa mosque to those israeli
marches these are usually national
religious very right-wing
people marching through the old city but
we are seeing also this morning
very heavy confrontations between
palestinian youth eyewitness
are saying that the israeli police is
using stun grenades
and tear gas and palestinian youth are
throwing rocks
and according to the red question there
are dozens of injured already it's a
developing situation
and we will be surely looking at that
giving you more on that during the day
you mentioned those confrontations tanya
we've got some live pictures that we're
going to play now
from jerusalem that's showing what's
happening right now
we've been seeing these clashes in
jerusalem for several days now
what is fueling them
well there are several reasons um that
is
you know it has been uh tense in the
city for
at least the past three weeks starting
you know with
police israeli police putting barriers
uh in one of the central plazas in
east jerusalem in front of damascus gate
we had also march of ultra
far right extr jewish extremist on east
jerusalem
two weeks ago but there's also another
issue that is fueling those tensions is
a the potential
eviction of four palestinian families
from one of the palestinian
neighborhoods in sheikh
in next east jerusalem
we have been talking to one of the
daughters of one of the families
they are facing eviction in favor of
jewish settlers
let's have a look muna alcort is
documenting everything that happens here
for social media
her family is one of four families
facing eviction from their homes in the
palestinian neighborhood
of sheikh sharach in east jerusalem
right-wing settlers could soon move in
here
this is our life as palestinians we are
the owners of the land we lived here
legally
and everything is documented legally
they come here and occupy the place and
they want to occupy what remains of the
neighborhood
this part of the house has already been
taken over by jewish settlers a decade
ago
just like across the street where
settlers moved into this house
they claim parts of this neighborhood is
actually their land
and have waged a lengthy court battle
against the families
it belonged to jews for almost
100 years jews lived there
and jews own the land since then
nothing changed beside one thing that
the arabs suddenly decided
that they are the owners of their land
of the property
and they decided not to accept
the jewish ownership like other
palestinian families who live in this
neighborhood
they were resettled here by jordan and
the un after the israeli arab war in
1948.
they'd lost everything after being
displaced at that time
israeli law prevents them from claiming
their lost properties
unless the supreme court allows a new
appeal there are no other legal options
for the family
it's very painful very tiring
psychologically speaking
we are exhausted each one of us has
packed a bag
with the most important papers passport
identity cards
anything important like certificates
from school and university
in case they evict us and that's what we
need to take with us
at sunset residents and supporters come
together to break their ramadan fast
soon after skirmishes break out at some
point armed riot police harshly
dispersed the crowd
arresting some of the palestinian
protesters
the eviction battle over the homes is
like a symbol of what's at stake
in the israeli-palestinian conflict
[Music]
families like the one in your report
have been awaiting a
court decision on whether or not they're
going to be evicted
that decision i understand has been
postponed why
well exactly that's what happened the uh
supreme court of the high court of
justice in israel has postponed
the hearing that was scheduled actually
uh for today
from last week and
they could have made a potential
decision on this pending eviction
in favor of this jewish settler
organization
who claims the land also the attorney
general of israel has
submitted to postpone the hearing to
weigh
in on the case now this gives the
families a brief respite so to speak
they can stay in their homes for now
but it doesn't uh actually cancel the
decision by
a lower court that already authorized
the eviction
after lengthy court battle uh by this
jewish settler organizations back in
february
um so basically it doesn't also change
the root causes we heard it in the
report about this
very controversial legislation and there
are also other families in the middle of
court proceedings
uh that are facing uh pending eviction
that are under threat of eviction in the
coming months
johnny thank you very much that was our
jerusalem correspondent tanya kramer
you